new polls have come out this week
multiple new polls showing that the
indictment from last week is not helping
Donald Trump at all
now shortly after the indictment about a
day or two later Donald Trump got on
Truth social and uh you know attacked
the prosecutors as he's been doing but
he also mentioned in one of those posts
on true socials my poll numbers have
gone through the roof
and to an extent with the Republican
base they absolutely have
but if you're just going to cherry pick
the data then sure you can pretty much
use it to prove whatever you want to
prove so you got to look at the bigger
picture which is something Donald Trump
doesn't want people to do because his
approval rating
ever since those indictments came down
has tanked Four Points dropping from an
already historically low 29 percent
all the way down to 25 percent